so we tend to view evolution and natural
selection and
the formation of new species which is
often called speciation
as a slow process that could take tens
or hundreds of thousands of years or in
many cases millions of years
and that's why it's always interesting
to see examples of when it might
actually be happening
more on a human time frame so this right
over here is a picture of a male
central european black cap so
historically
central european black caps would spend
their summers
in central europe right over here in
what we would now consider
germany so let me write summer right
over here
and then when it gets colder in central
europe they would
migrate and spend their winters in spain
so this is where they would spend their
winters now whenever we talk about
migratory patterns like this it's always
interesting to note that
it's not that all of the birds always go
on the exact same migration path
as we've talked about in many videos you
tend to have variation in a population
there are birds that because of genetic
differences they might go in other
directions they might go that way
they might go that way they might go
that way but those
variants probably weren't successful
some of them might end up in the north
sea some of them might end up freezing
to death
some of them might not be able to have
sources of food while the
dominant variant that wintered in spain
was successful it was warmer there
they had access to food now this is
where it gets interesting
in the 1960s and 1970s it became
more and more popular to put backyard
bird feeders
in england and so some of those
central european black caps just
happened to go in
that direction they might have always
been happening to go there some
small percentage of the population but
those didn't do so well
but now all of a sudden you have these
backyard bird feeders in england
and so these birds were able to be quite
successful they were able to get food
they were able to thrive
and so over time this became a larger
and larger proportion
that was able to successfully go in that
direction and then migrate back in the
summer and then
reproduce now not only did that gene
not get selected against and now the
birds that had the genes to go in that
direction
were thriving but they also started
mating with each other more and more
frequently
because they would all get back to
germany earlier because when the winter
ended they had a shorter distance to
travel on the way back
than the ones that went to spain and so
as they started reproducing with each
other
more and more and more we started to see
differences
beyond migration direction in these two
groups of central european black caps
the ones that traveled northwest started
to see
rounder wings versus pointier
wings for the ones that were
historically going to spain
well pointer wings are better for
traveling long distances
and rounder wings are more maneuverable
if you don't have to travel as long of a
distance
that is more desirable now it's not like
these birds knew that they needed
rounder wings
but once again even in the pool that was
going to the northwest
you would have had variations some
pointy wings some round wings
but the round wings might have been more
successful so that became
a more pronounced trait in that group
while
similarly the ones that went to spain
some of them might have had rounder
wings
but they might not have been as
successful to get all the way to spain
and back so the pointier wings
that phenotype seemed to thrive so this
is an example how
an environmental change and here the
environmental change is people deciding
to put bird feeders in their backyards
in england in the 1960s and 1970s
has actually over just the course of
roughly 30 or 40 generations
begun what some biologists view as a
speciation event
the ones that go northwest can still
interbreed with the ones that go to the
southwest
but over time if the two groups keep
breeding amongst themselves because of
the timing of their migration
they might not be able to interbreed
anymore and then you would have
two different species so this is just
one example
there are many other examples about how
the physical environment can contribute
to the expansion of some species
the emergence of new distinct species
or in certain situations cause a decline
in a species and in the extreme
and extinction which we'll talk about in
another video